a regular
but vision could immediately disguise
himself as a regular husband as easy as
he could try to hide under his hat right
and then he continues the indecent
exposure by walking around
unprotected outside in complete view
also yes i understand that there's
surely some element of magic slash
wackiness slash dreamworld
spoilers going on here so anything could
not be what it seems but you know what
is as it seems me giving sins whenever
the hell i want to
dropping your wife taking dick van
dyke's name in vain or
really taking the name dick van dyke at
all also
how is wanda's dress able to pass
through the chair as well that's not
part of vision's body
also also this chair has no business
being in the middle of the room like
this
later we see it doesn't live there so
who dragged this chair out here in the
first place
taking time to dance while the door is
still wide open do you want the
neighbors to see you
in the 50s this is basically the
equivalent to having sex in your
driveway
i see someone went to the mary poppins
school of cleaning things but if you can
control reality
why are you even floating things around
or messing with towels and such why mess
with telekinesis when you just
change actual reality also this is a
neat trick and all but you also need to
dry out the inside of the glass which
you do not appear to be doing and that
will be a glass of bacteria before long
do you want herpes wanda because this is
how you get ants i mean herpes
also also considering they make such a
big deal about her hiding her powers
from everyone else
maybe don't do this in front of an open
window where any passing neighbor could
see
even if you're making fun of laugh
tracks it's still a laugh track
which means it's still a sin oh
thank you i say oh i don't eat food
well that explains empty refrigerator
but wanda eats
so that refrigerator should have a few
things in it right well then tell me
what's so important about today's date
can we have a sitcom plot involves a
main character for getting an important
date cliche in a satire slash parody
making fun of the sitcom plot involves
the main character for getting an
important day cliche
and if we do doesn't that just make us a
youtube channel that pokes fun at tv
shows making a cliche out of a cliche
cliche
and if so what even am i do i exist am i
a cliche
why is my narration hello dear i'm agnes
your neighbor to the right
my right not yours people that say my
right not yours instead of just saying
to the left
golly you settled in fast did you use a
moving company
agnes just apologized for not visiting
sooner which means it's been at least a
few days since wanda moved in so what is
agnes shocked about the living room
consists of a few pieces of furniture a
coat rack by the front door and some
nicks and a few necks
no it's not a holiday an anniversary
then
yes this is our anniversary
elizabeth olsen is so good at balancing
the old sitcom tone in this but i have
to give her a sin off for it in fact
there's so much that's amazing about
this recreation from the sets to the
camera style to the laugh tracks that i
should probably go ahead and give
several sins off but honestly you made
me think of laugh tracks as a positive
thing so just be happy with the one
removal show
the only way ralph would remember our
anniversary is if there was a beer named
june
2nd but how would that help him remember
he might remember the beer was named
june 2nd but that wouldn't guarantee the
significance would dawn on him and if
you're remembering important things like
anniversaries while consuming alcohol
you're not beering right
and let me tell you what ralph could
really use is how to goose your wife so
you don't
lose your wife pretending goose rhymes
with lose hey the music isn't bothering
you is it pal
in terms of distraction from work or the
largely nonsensical nature of the lyrics
nonsensical what's so nonsensical about
take out the papers or the trash or you
don't get no spending cash
yakityak is a pretty straightforward
song about parents ordering around their
kids
it's not like someone's asking who put
the bomb in
but also who did put the bomb in the
bomb bomb and which bop of the three
bombs are they even responsible for
also i think i just send music somebody
should make a youtube channel that does
that
also also playing music of any kind at
your desk in a shared office what is it
we're producing
computational forms then when vision
asks norm what they did there why didn't
he reply with this
norm even said they didn't make anything
but clearly they're making computational
forms
no skeletons in your closet ambition if
he goes through the trouble of creating
a false identity why wouldn't he just
give himself a more normal name
like carl well you're not darling i
still get a little tongue tied
he fizz after all this
time couple thinks they're talking about
two different things but the
conversation still somehow works to
maintain the miscommunication cliche and
yes that's likely the point but consider
it a sin for the cliche even existing in
the first place
is your husband tired of you burning his
toast commercials
seriously someone should make a youtube
channel that sends those also this
lobster looks like it
and with this chicken hanging above it
it's clear that this room goes by the
1950s two
and a clock standard of interior design
also also parody of a commercial within
the parody of a sitcom and i'm sure when
this is all said and done we'll be wowed
by the ingenious nature of the whole
thing but right now my brain is over
parodied in an over parity brain leads
to horrible things
like watching two and a half men
marathons struggles are real people
oh and now you're using color in a black
and white world is an indicator that
something is different
i think someone saw pleasantville too
many times and if i remember my
pleasantville
incorrectly this means the toaster has
recently masturbated
how very atmospheric and fire hazardy
guess who look mistakes happen i once
patted the butt of a woman because she
looked like my wife from behind but
there are so many context clues that
this isn't vision that this makes
absolutely no sense
including oh i don't know the other
human woman in the room
we don't break bread with [ __ ]
that's bolshevist
and marxist and communist that man
through there is my boss mr heart
and since you're keeping your voice at
top volume he can hear all of this
explanation and i'm sure everything will
be resolved and there will be no more
hijinks to maneuver
the heart on the calendar was an
abbreviation
you move at the speed of sound and i can
make a pen float through the air who
needs to abbreviate
wanda would be excellent at tv sins the
candle is the music that
stunning outfit i understand vision is
some sort of fleshy android ai thing
and there's probably some way you could
simulate sexual desires but it doesn't
make me any less weirded out by it
although it's still less odd than the
sweater he wore in captain america civil
war
i might have a better idea oh sure when
you need to change out of your clothes
you make it happen with a snap but when
you need to cook dinner you'll go back
to pretending you have to do things
telekinetically
just asking for some consistency here
let's take out the papers and the trash
even if mrs hart turned around in time
before seeing any of wanda's powers
mr hart would still be able to see the
display from his position in the living
room
well why don't we have a nice sing-along
all together then shall we
convenient ukulele is convenient oh no
too much
oh no not enough is the opposite of an
overcooked chicken a couple dozen eggs
even if it's not an undercooked chicken
shouldn't it just be one egg
wouldn't you know what good news is more
expensive 24-hour cable news networks
it might be breakfast for dinner but
drinking wine with any kind of breakfast
serving is gross
and also a sin where did you two move
from
what brought you here how long have you
been married and why don't you have
children yet
nosy neighbors i will now be googling
the name babs digby for the next hour or
so
trying to figure out if it's a clue as
to where this show is headed so am i
sending a show for inspiring me to do
some research
yeah i am plot tease cliffhangers tease
hangers
peter breakfast for dinner is anarchy
tired
[Music]
i know the stereotype i'm a woman
got a luscious body provocative clothes
i'm gonna use sex to sell cars
oh no i'm not single oh i don't see a
ring
mind your own goddamn business gene what
is the purpose of this company
i don't want to sell anything buy
anything or process anything as a career
hello peter what's happening what about
seduction techniques
this is the essence
of sex
this is taking too long i'm gonna miss
the farmer's market
from meatloaf to cherry pie to
open-faced cheese sandwiches
mmm open-faced club sandwich
place our anniversary our anniversary
what oh
[Applause]